is now breaking news alert
we're getting more information now from
that deadly shooting in the mirage hotel
this is a very active homicide
investigation sasha loftis joins us from
the scene with more sasha
denise as you said a very active
situation as i mentioned a few minutes
ago the mirage has reopened to guess it
was shut down for a while when we got
out here we saw some people on the other
side of crime scene tape with luggage
waiting to get back into their room some
say they were evacuated asked to leave
they were inside when this happened
metro police tell us that one person was
shot and killed inside the mirage hotel
and casino metro i-team sources rather
tell us that
possibly others were hurt as well again
this is an active situation if you look
closely here you can see those police
lights in the distance that entire valet
area of the mirage is covered in police
this is as close as we can get but you
can see it through those trees there now
we did speak with a few guests who were
staying here they were out at dinner at
the time but they did hear police come
over here just really heard the
commotion take a listen
yeah this first time i've seen where the
police have gone over the center media
just to get up down here and they just
weren't
going full speed down here so
something's going on
now the people we talked to outside here
again they are allowed to go back into
their rooms but a lot of them were just
startled to hear something like this
what happened inside a hotel along the
strip now as you mentioned this is
really a fluid situation we are waiting
for more information from police we do
expect a briefing from metro police
coming up at about a half an hour at 11
45. stay with 8 news now on air and
online for the latest on that for now
reporting live sasha loftis live local
now